well that's over with for now so you've
heard the definition of crazy doing the
same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result
well the Democrats invented a new kind
of crazy knowing the outcome of an event
well in advance and still expecting a
different result
that's impeachment the worst planned
adventure since the Donner Party the
Dems blew all their energy on a losers
bet one that made the iowa mess possible
instead of Wow in America they fell flat
on their faces because they were
distracted I returned a return to Greg's
rule Republicans run things
Democrats ruin them the difference is
one letter which stands for impeachment
so once again the losers return to their
hallucinations the snakes on the wall
they're real if you're Adam Schiff
because now Trump could offer Alaska to
the Russians Trump could offer Alaska to
the Russians in exchange for support in
the next election damn Adams so nutty he
farts trail mix but hey it beats moving
tomorrow Lago or decide to move tomorrow
Lago permanently and let Jared Kushner
run the country so why cling to these
crazy predictions because they don't
exist which means you can't disprove
them and the response will always be
well you just wait there like imaginary
mice and shifts the crazy coot on the
table screaming but those mad ravings
had us waiting for the stock market
crash a tyranny World War three four and
five all paranoid nightmares that never
came instead all we got were stock
market highs trade deals dead terrorists
and jobs and since those successes are
under Trump the delusions only deepen
without a real vision beyond anger they
cling to these mental phantoms look
early on we told the Dems impeachment
was a dead fish we said don't follow
Adam he's selling you drugs that only
end in bad trips but did they listen
nope to them bad drugs are better than
no drugs which is why they'll be back in
the lab coming up with a new paranoia
pill but we know not to gulp them let
them have them all because we saw it
coming but they have it coming all right
she's where to start Jessie big fat
waste of time the only winner in this
whole thing
we the network is pulling in millions of
eyeballs
god knows what the ad money is it's a
lot like second homes buying a third
home and I don't even have a second home
I have a fourth home on top of my third
home okay I mean stop bragging damn it
I'm realizing Ellis my sixth home is
dating my seventh home okay well when
I'm your age maybe I'll have a second
one when I got on this set you asked me
are you pumped and I said about what and
you said about the acquittal and I
thought to myself we knew this was gonna
happen this is like when your wife or
your husband makes you go out to dinner
to another couple's house who you hate
ah you have to go right is it the food
is terrible you know you're gonna have a
bad time eventually it's gonna be over
and you're gonna be back in bed and
you're gonna say I told you honey that
the one at my house and then just to say
something to have a Trump impeachment
and you don't have any sex you don't
even have a dead body you don't have a
suitcase full of cash in a freezer this
is the lamest impeachment ever if this
also to your point about what you said
in the monologue have these crazy
predictions it's the same thing with
global warming in 20 years the Miami's
gonna be underwater and if you say um I
don't think that's possible
they say oho you got to believe me and
by the way that you got to give me all
your money that's the same thing it's a
stick-up scam I didn't fall for it
because I told you the whole time what
was gonna happen
you didn't listen what are you happy one
are you happy because it looks like it
backfired why do you think it backfire
I'm just saying cuz Biden got damaged oh
yeah you're not gonna retake the Senate
Trump's at 49% approval and what did we
learn there was a phone call and the
transcripts came out I learned I was
right we learned mail I knew that
beforehand well you're always right
thank you but I will say I think
impeachment led most the American people
now to understand that this is a corrupt
president
they said in essence and this was the
Republican line even if he did it we
don't think it's quite impeachable wait
till the election as if the forefathers
didn't think about elections so you have
now I'm just gonna give you a few
senator Rubio senator Portman senator
Toomey senator Collins senator Murkowski
and of course Senator Romney who voted
to convict all saying the president did
something wrong embarrassing
inappropriate all of this you just we
saw that trick there want you just group
to Romney with people who didn't vote to
know what I'm just telling ya that's
what they said they said that the house
managers made a convincing case but
we're not going to convict I mean I I
think Romney should be honored for as a
man of principle in this case because at
least he voted with his heart not about
power we're avoiding Trump's tweets I
mean to me what you get here is this is
what Republicans in the Senate had to
say and then they you know what they
just said unfold you know boy we don't
want Donald Trump saying nasty things
yeah that's good mind reading that's
what we're all thinking
Katie what do you think well I was a
little bit surprised at the vote with
Joe Manchin I thought he would maybe
vote to acquit the president on at least
one of the articles considering in West
Virginia the president is very popular
and it would have been politically safe
for him to do so but he voted with
Democrats this was predicted as a
bipartisan acquittal it did not end up
being that way but there's obviously
going to be a lot made of Mitt Romney's
vote I don't think that it really
matters because the president has a 95
percent approval in the GOP the American
people have given him an approval rating
at the highest that he's seen throughout
his presidency throughout the trial Adam
Schiff is trying to say that he's going
to cheat and steal and they you can't
trust the American people to make
decisions in the next election I think
people put probably took that pretty
personally and so moving forward I don't
think that his vote really matters when
it comes to the numbers and the
president has had a lot of wins and as
soon as Mitt Romney does something that
Democrats disapprove of he will no
longer be the moral clarity that they're
claiming today and I'd like to go back
to the election against Barack Obama
when they're calling him a racist they
were calling him an animal abuser and of
course he was waging a war on women so
you know maybe some of those people can
take back some of the thing
that they said about him at that point
yeah the women in the binder yeah the
binders full of women Dana what if you
have thoughts on Democratic fatalism
well I think partly Pelosi did you write
that down article yet the it was written
by John Ellis I'm sure it's very good
[Music]
Nancy Pelosi was also telling them for
months don't do this it's going to
backfire it's not a good idea and that
but she did feel pushed by the
progressive right and who where else do
you see being pushed by progressives
well you could look at after 2016 what
did Bernie Sanders do we got the DNC to
change everything and how's that working
out for them yeah and so I think her
frustration last night was not only just
at the president but also at her caucus
like looking at them thinking you know I
told you this was gonna happen and now
they're in a fix
yeah and the president looks like he's
just gonna waltz right back into the
White House for a second term obviously
it's not gonna be that easy but right
now it feels that way yeah it hasn't
gotten any worse for him and it's gotten
better since then I think we have some
sound on tape of Mitch McConnell smiling
Speaker of the House says she refuses to
accept this acquittal whatever that
means
perhaps you will tear up the verdict
like she tore up the State of the Union
address there is no sign this attack on
our institutions will end here whatever
policy differences we may have we should
all agree this is precisely the kind of
recklessness the kind of recklessness
the Senate was created to Scott what do
you make of that Jesse well I think he
did a very good job as majority leader
in the Senate and he deserves a lot of
credit for gotting this through I think
that Nancy tried to bully him and Mitch
McConnell is not a man to be bullied and
that's very clear this was not a close
vote they were 20 votes short of
conviction
it's not even in like the realm of
possibility it was a partisan vote which
is the whole point of the 2/3
67 they got 20 votes less than that and
you look at the Muller investigation and
now this impeachment trial Trump's clean
Trump is an innocent man he has been
found guilty of zero crimes and one you
said now that the American people are
completely convinced this is a corrupt
president I would say this I think the
American people aren't going to believe
any accusation by the Democrats against
the president anymore especially if it
because it comes from an anonymous
intelligence official like the last two
hoaxes have come from and that's your
fault because you didn't do it in the
sunlight you did it behind closed doors
and that's not the way you take out the
pressure you can keep arguing the
process I think the reason I asked you
if you were pumped was the man basically
he's got away with it this is the man on
Fifth Avenue shooting someone is he
Spragg and his followers saying nothing
and after Muller phone call where there
was all this evidence again he says uh I
was exonerated it's unbelievable and we
can expect to hear that I hear he's
gonna give a statement tomorrow I'm
expect he'll do that and he'll play to
the base again I guess you go I want to
add finish here is basically what
Republicans said today is Donald Trump
if you want to do this again if you want
to reach out to the Russians to the
Chinese if you want to blame the
Ukrainians do whatever you want because
you Donald Trump okay you know the best
term I heard today what's a dur Whitson
which is basically this show wet sand oh
sure with this I was like what it was
which means that any time the president
acts as long as he thinks it helps his
election and he thinks his election is
the best center of the country it's okay
that's a quote I did you know we talked
about this on the show with residences
read the trans yeah I know I ready now
what it said is that it's in the
interest of the of the country yeah then
it obviously helps them in realize
that's easy because you got a real like
Donald Trump
adding that your mind-reading your
adding a second parts what he said he
said if the President believes his
re-election is the best interest of
country whatever he does fine go for it
you are investigating corruption or if
you're trying to make a Middle East
peace deal that will actually help it
just happens to help you get elected
that doesn't negate it it's called a
mixed motive but let me just ask one a
quick question because I really want to
hear his answer okay his Trump innocent
until proven guilty everybody's innocent
thank you but that's not a try I would
argue that Juan keeps talking about the
process and how it does it it really
shouldn't matter and that Republicans
focusing on it that is a distraction but
in America the process is everything and
the reason why Democrats are in the
position that they are now is because
they didn't go through the process in
the house to make sure that they had a
solid case that was ready to send to the
Senate which is exactly why Nancy Pelosi
was steamrolled by her caucus from the
beginning on this impeachment process
but we are moving on to more of Nancy
Pelosi's behavior and just a minute but
president Trump just tweeted about the
vote this afternoon he said I will be
making a public statement tomorrow at
12:00 p.m. from the White House to
discuss our country's victory on the
impeachment quote a hoax
end quote also of note the media and
Democrats told us it was a rock-solid
case but that has fallen flat we have a
very locked solid case I think the case
we have if presented to a jury would be
a guilty verdict and about three minutes
flat he has in fact committed and
regional offenses the president
committed the offenses charged in the
first article of impeachment the
Congress now knows that the president
has committed impeachable offenses the
president is guilty he is guilty of
committing impeachable offenses the
president is guilty every fact shows
that the president is guilty of these
impeachable offenses and Democrats might
not be done here's what house in Petrik
manager Jerry Nadler said earlier so
give it everything show everything you
remember
the investigations on the motor report
that we're never finished because
because we didn't get the witnesses
we're in court to begin and others get
those Dana is this ever going to end
well I was thinking something Mitch
McConnell has said several times which
is there's nothing more you can learn
from the second kick of a mule and it's
like when you're touching the hot stove
you're like wow oh gosh don't ever do
that again you do it once when you're a
kid and then you are cautious III again
I still like to still think that Nancy
Pelosi as part of her frustration has to
be that she got pushed into it then they
had then that now they ought to say the
same thing they're all trying to say the
same thing everybody's in their corners
but the president is actually come out
on top and improve all these numbers
that are improving that could happen it
doesn't happen overnight but it's been
pretty quickly this has been going on
for six months and the country has been
paying attention
Americans are smart and they've figured
out how they feel about it and they
think that one they want to move on and
second they think that they can fight
this out at the ballot box and now
that's just not me know six months is a
long time especially right before an
election and now we're at just nine
months before you could you know you
could have a baby
between now and then so you meant
something I said you could have I do not
have a womb Dana you know what maybe
they should keep impeaching him because
it makes them feel good it a Q PI's the
Democrats headspace and it does let's be
honest it does make Trump better because
he loves a good fight it's like better
than a Malta Flintstones multivitamin it
gets him going and it makes him this is
the other thing makes him more
sympathetic Trump to the victim Juan is
that right he's been victimized by
millions of Democrats and all of your
investigators for many many years and
that's why everybody feels sorry for the
man he could put up with that much but I
must say Mitt Romney I thought you said
oh I believe there was a bipartisan vote
what guy oh I think Mitt Romney but what
happened to Republican unity on that
front they lie
I don't see that christen cinema right
Democrat what happened doesn't have to
worry about it's gonna get beat by just
what her legs out I need a career after
I know with my Senate in the party no I
don't know but what happened to Joe
Manchin Oh remember people don't vote on
principle just vote to retain your power
partisan force it was bipartisan it from
the heart as opposed to a poet why is
voting for bipartisan are you 52 I want
a Democrat votes guilty that's from the
heart because when a Republican votes
acquit that's political I mean you're so
what's the difference because I'm gonna
tell you what Republicans said Rubio
Portman to me Collins Murkowski ed
Romney all said his actions were
inappropriate and I would like to hear
from on they're not the only ones that
have said that like there are people
like Annie McCarthy from the very
beginning it was like well they should
the house should just do the censure
vote they should walk away because
otherwise this is gonna walk them right
into impeachment there's a lot of
Republicans who have said all of those
things but don't think that it was in
peach' Bowl I don't think that that's so
out of the realm and I think overstating
the Romney factor of the one person that
decided to vote on one of the articles
to convict and saying that that
basically shattered Republican unity is
a little bit I don't say no I just said
it's a fact in other words there was the
fact there's a Republican
judge he was hollow and I know that you
know right here at Fox News it's been
saying all along this guy committed
impeachable offenses but so I was wrong
love you judge it's the it's the power
equation get elected protect yourself
hey well the Trump bully is gonna talk
about after the trial after the truck
now that this is over what do you guys
gonna complain about
I'm not complain they'll do it again
we're gonna have to focus on the
Democrats let me you don't want to do
that because that's a mess over there
yeah the media you're gonna be forced to
focus on the Democrat primary you don't
have this catchment anymore you don't
have another Trump
scandal right now that you're cooking up
you have to focus on the Democrat
primary and that's going to be a
nightmare that's it you really do you
really think that they're not going to
try and come up with some other scam oh
they gotta come up with something quick
Katie I mean look it's still a fact half
the American people think this guy
should have been impeached like they did
before that's true before impeachment
even start no no no Pelosi none of this
has been in closest favor from the
beginning she had to go back on her word
and say by part Pietschmann had to be
bipartisan from the beginning Democrats
joined Republicans in the house to vote
against it and here we are now with not
the results that you think that you
should have based on what you think the
American people want but it was
political from the beginning and the
reflection of the impeachment polls
reflects exactly how people come down
what they're voting on and the momentum
on this has been towards the president
from the start
I mean the poll numbers that
bipartisanship from the front end I
think that's been on his side people
have gone to that okay well I think you
know when I was watching they were the
end of this vote they all started
getting all friendly again you see that
likewise in this chummy and they started
thanking people they should thank the
American people for putting up and
sitting through this circus and thank us
for being so cogent in our analysis and
seeing through this and being right all
along
I didn't hear a thank you from them I
didn't hear it and I'm personally
offended I actually do want to say I was
right all told you from the very
beginning that this was a phone call
these were weak articles and there was
going to be an acquittal but all you did
was whine the whole time and you didn't
listen to what always said and the fact
that Mitt Romney listened to a brilliant
legal presentation and he's a smart guy
and he came down on the side of guilty
makes me think I don't think he was
really open to hearing the legal
analysis because why would you vote for
more witnesses if you were still
open-minded in thinking about oh maybe
this isn't a closed case and then you
get no witnesses and then you vote to
convict it was a strong case but in fact
if you have John
sitting out there if you have documents
even today thank God for documents
coming out that indicate the president
was intent on using this influence for
his political it's basically never gonna
whine nothing but I just continuing it
you're saying john bolton maybe if i
don't know
oh no no I just think that he sit John
Bolton sitting out there right
yeah the president sitting out there
who's there the whistleblower yes
yeah Graham's gonna call him oh my god
we're gonna hear from them and Hunter
bite into but we are going to move on